en una carpa a las afueras del hospital
en la capital de martinica este doctor
que llegó para ayudar desde francia
evalúa pacientes con kobe 19 llegó hace
dos semanas para dar apoyo de emergencia
a sus colegas locales
al cabo de cuatro semanas de
confinamiento se ve una mejoría aunque
las primeras semanas el caos reinaba en
las salas de urgencias era un desastre
se sentía como si no hubiera nada que se
pudiera hacer fue demasiado imposible
como intentar vaciar el océano con una
cuchara no se puede hacer era
profundamente triste el hospital sigue
al máximo de su capacidad hospitalaria
pero el flujo constante de ambulancias
ha disminuido el confinamiento estricto
ha sido extendido hasta el menos el 19
de septiembre y el inicio de clases ha
sido por al menos dos semanas
en varios de los territorios de las
antillas francesas
para usted se decidió esta mañana
durante el consejo de defensa de salud
pública correr el inicio del año escolar
al 13 de septiembre en guadalupe
martinica san martín y san bartolomeo
así como parte de la guyana francesa que
se encuentra en zona roja
la tasa de contagio en martinica ha
bajado 875 casos por 100.000 habitantes
comparado con 1200 de la semana pasada
en francia el número de casos es de un
poco más de 200 contagios por 100.000
habitantes los territorios caribeños aún
tienen una de las más bajas tasas de
vacunación en el país menos de un cuarto
de la población está completamente
vacunada en guadalupe como en martinica